Transcriptor: Sonia García
Revisor: Penny Martínez
Desde que empezamos
a estudiar el universo,
este siempre nos ha devuelto
el mismo mensaje:
"Sois insignificantes".
(Risas)
Y, cada vez, lo hace
de una manera más rotunda.
De creernos en el centro del universo,
aquí en la Tierra con los astros
girando a nuestro alrededor,
el Sol pasa a ocupar
nuestro lugar en el siglo XVI.
Y ya, con los locos años 20,
la cosa se desmadra.
Pasamos a ocupar
un ladito anodino de la Vía Láctea:
una galaxia entre muchas otras.
Esta cura de humildad
es algo que, en realidad,
nos ha costado muchos cientos de años.
Y más sabiendo que la vida
se ralentiza mucho sin los ordenadores.
Entre el sistema de Tolomeo
con la Tierra en el centro
y el sistema de Copérnico
con el Sol en el centro,
hay una distancia de 1400 años.
Hace poco, un equipo de científicos
de la Universidad de Zúrich,
se preguntó si podíamos
haber reducido estos años,
si podíamos haber llegado
a estas conclusiones
acerca de nuestra posición
en el cosmos mucho antes
utilizando aquellos datos,
datos sencillos, astronómicos,
pero haciendo una trampita:
con ciertas capacidades
informáticas actuales.
¿En cuánto se podrían haber
reducido esos 1400 años?
Después os lo cuento.
(Risas)
Los ordenadores están siendo
unos asistentes muy útiles
para la comunidad científica.
Hoy en día, el desarrollo
de la ciencia es impensable
sin nuestros esclavos mecánicos.
Os suena esta imagen, probablemente:
la primera fotografía de un agujero negro.
Una imagen que dio la vuelta al mundo,
y que es técnicamente mucho más complicada
que tratar de tomar
una fotografía desde aquí
a la cabecita de un alfiler
localizado en Central Park
con nuestra camára de bolsillo.
Ese agujero negro está
a 55 millones de años luz.
Esto es mucho más allá
de los confines de nuestra galaxia.
Esta imagen, en realidad,
es una recreación.
Es un puzle muy sofisticado
que hemos construido
a partir de unir pedacitos de información
que hemos recopilado
desde diferentes partes del mundo:
desde telescopios ubicados
en volcanes en Hawái y en México,
desde las montañas de Arizona,
desde la Sierra Nevada española,
desde el desierto de Atacama en Chile,
e incluso desde la Antártida.
Un triunfo de la cooperación
científica a gran escala.
Y es que, además,
los miembros del equipo científico
tuvieron que transportar los datos
manualmente en discos duros,
porque los archivos
eran demasiado grandes,
y ninguna conexión
a internet puede rivalizar
con la velocidad de transferencia
de meter esos discos duros en un avión.
No puede rivalizar.
Y todo ese despliege
para producir una imagen
que al final solo tiene
unos 100x100 megapíxeles.
Porque es fruto de un algoritmo
que la ha compuesto después
de reducir los datos y de combinarlos.
Sobre todo este asunto,
yo creo que hay otra imagen
que también dio la vuelta
al mundo a la vez,
y que creo que a algunos
los emocionó todavía más:
la de su creadora, Katie Bouman,
la estudiante de doctorado
que creó el código y que
no puede contener su emoción
al ver esa primera representación
visual del agujero negro,
ahi, en su ordenador portátil.
Porque con ese corazón de silicio impávido
que tienen los ordenadores,
pueden trabajar con los datos
durante horas,
y durante días, y durante meses.
Y ni se aburren,
ni se cansan, ni se quejan.
Al menos de momento.
La primera vez que yo cogí
un conjunto de datos
de galaxias reales de un catálogo...
Estos son puntitos, coordenadas
que vienen en un archivo
que te dicen dónde están localizadas
estas galaxias en el espacio.
Probé a insertarlos en un programita
que me había diseñado en el ordenador,
a ver qué pasaba.
Por supuesto, introduje unas ecuaciones
para acotar apropiadamente
el volumen sobre el que estaba trabajando,
y le di a "ejecutar",
no sin antes lidiar con
todos los bucles algorítmicos,
los errores del código,
todas estas cosas, etc.,
y ...¡voilà!
Ahí estaba un pedacito de universo.
Mi libro de geometría abierto a un lado,
los restos infames de alguna comida
al otro lado del escritorio,
y ahí delante, en la pantalla,
un trozo de universo.
Con la distribución real
de 14 247 galaxias.
La estimación actual es
que hay dos trillones de galaxias
en el universo observable,
que es el fragmento del cosmos que
podemos ver potencialmente desde la Tierra.
Pero ¿créeis que realmente
hemos registrado con los telescopios
todos esos cientos de miles
de millones de galaxias?
No. Existen limitaciones.
Limitaciones de dos tipos.
Limitaciones técnicas:
no podemos barrer todo el espacio
con los telescopios.
Y también limitaciones físicas.
A medida que yo miro más lejos
con el telescopio,
la imagen que obtengo
es mucho más engañosa,
porque a medida que
avanzo en profundidad,
los objetos que voy encontrando
son más remotos en el espacio,
pero también en el tiempo.
Esto es una especie
de trabajo arqueológico.
Si nosotros excavamos la tierra,
probablemente en las capas superiores
encontremos restos de huesos humanos;
un poquito más abajo,
restos de dinosaurios;
y mucho más abajo, de las primeras
células, del origen de la vida.
En astrofísica, estudiamos
distintos estratos del cielo
hasta casi llegar al Big Bang.
Por lo tanto, para hacernos
una composición
de toda la escena cósmica,
para entender cómo es
el universo hoy en día,
nos valemos de simulaciones informáticas.
Tenemos que tomar pedacitos del cielo,
mirar en esos trocitos,
extrapolar la información,
hacer aproximaciones estadísticas
y meterlas en la simulación.
Y a través de la simulación,
podemos conocer
cómo evoluciona el universo,
cómo cambia con el tiempo.
No solo nos sirven para hacer recreaciones
de objetos como el agujero negro.
También nos sirven para comprender
las dinámicas del cosmos.
Sí. Nos sirven para comprender
las dinámicas del cosmos,
porque la astrofísica presenta un desafío
que no es común a otras ciencias.
Y es que no podemos
experimentar con los astros,
no podemos manipular el universo.
Yo no puedo hacer estallar una supernova,
ni puedo hacer que dos galaxias
colisionen en lo que me dura un café,
un tiempo razonable para el ser humano.
Estudiar el universo
plantea un problema
científico-filosófico de base.
Y es que solo tenemos
un universo al que observar.
No puedo darle al "play"
y esperar que el universo se repita.
No puedo ejecutar
ese gran algoritmo cósmico,
cambiando, por ejemplo, una pizquita
las condiciones iniciales,
a ver qué pasa.
No puedo hacer eso en astrofísica.
Bueno, lo que hacemos en astronomía
es hacer simulaciones.
Y para ello, lo que se utiliza
es una receta muy clara.
Tengo una idea de los procesos físicos
que ocurren en el mundo,
introduzco estas hipótesis
dentro del ordenador,
dentro del programa informático.
Introduzco los datos
y dejo correr la simulación.
Y en base a lo que me devuelve,
me pregunto: ¿se parece a la realidad?
Observamos el mundo y lo representamos,
porque, a través de la ciencia, lo que
queremos es describir la naturaleza.
Queremos comprender, queremos
predecir y queremos dominar el mundo.
Esto no siempre ha sido así.
Probablemente, algunos
ahora estén pensando:
"Bueno, para el desarrollo de la ciencia
no siempre han sido necesarios
los ordenadores".
Nosotros podemos tener
modelos de universo,
pues acerca de si es estático,
si se expande, si se contrae,
con el ingenio humano.
No han sido imprescindibles siempre.
Por ejemplo, Edwin Hubble en los años 30,
dibujó 26 puntitos sobre un papel,
y una raya para gobernarlos a todos.
Estos 26 puntitos eran las galaxias
que él había observado con el telescopio.
Y esa pálida línea
que atravesaba su gráfica,
escondía una ley.
Escondía una proporción
en la que detrás se hallaba
uno de los cambios de paradigma
más importantes de la historia científica:
la idea de que vivimos
en un universo en expansión.
Observó que cuanto más lejos
estaban las galaxias,
más deprisa huían de nosotros.
Veintiséis puntitos y una raya.
Y habilidades intelectuales, por supuesto:
la inventiva, la capacidad
para extrapolar, la creatividad.
Lo que pasa es que en el mundo moderno
trabajamos con muchos, muchos datos.
Pensad que ahora en astrofísica,
con el Square Kilometer Array,
que es un telescopio que se va a poner
en marcha ahora en la década de 2020,
este telescopio va a producir
un tráfico de datos al año
que es equivalente al que tenemos
ahora en todo internet.
Claro, no podemos analizar,
no podemos afrontar
ese desafío de análisis.
Y gracias a estos progresos,
gracias a la asistencia informática,
podemos llegar a crear imágenes como esta,
imágenes tan imponentes.
Esto es un gran trozo de universo.
Un gran trozo.
Y en esta simulación está contenido
todo el inventario cósmico.
Ahí tenemos materia oscura,
tenemos materiay ordinaria,
todo agrupado en galaxias
que a su vez se agrupan
en supercúmulos de galaxias,
y en última instancia,
esta especie de telaraña cósmica
que a algunos les recuerda
a una red neuronal.
Y que si además,
dejamos correr la simulación,
le damos al "play",
nos devuelve el trepidante resultado
de que estamos abocados
al gran desgarro cósmico
y a que el espacio-tiempo reviente.
Bien, ¿os habéis dado cuenta
de que uno de los rasgos
más prolíficos de la ciencia
es la fertilización cruzada entre campos:
astronomía e informática?
También hay muchos ejemplos
en física y en biología.
Y ahora podríamos preguntarnos
qué pasa si unimos astrofísica
e inteligencia artificial.
Estamos en ese punto.
La pregunta que impera es:
los ordenadores, además de
proporcionarnos esa asistencia informática
para tratar con todas esas
grandes cantidades de datos,
¿serán capaces de convertirse
en nuevas fuerzas creativas,
capaces de proporcionar fórmulas,
de proporcionar modelos,
leyes del universo?
Hace poco que se ha desarrollado
un tipo de algoritmos de autoaprendizaje,
que además están
muy en boga a día de hoy,
que son las redes neuronales artificiales.
Se trata de una maniobra matemática,
cuyo funcionamiento está inspirado
en el cerebro humano.
Os hablo de una inteligencia artificial
que se alimenta solo de datos.
Aquellos científicos en Suiza
probaron a alimentar
a una de estas criaturitas,
dándole los datos
de las posiciones del Sol y de Marte
en diferentes momentos del tiempo,
vistos desde la Tierra.
Eso son datos que conocemos
desde hace muchísimos años.
Probaron alimentar
esa inteligencia artificial
y es que la receta ahora era distinta.
No asumieron nada,
nada acerca de los procesos físicos
que suceden en el mundo.
Solo le metieron los datos
y, de los datos en sí,
la inteligencia artificial
aprendió a predecir las posiciones
futuras de estos dos astros.
Y decidió que la manera
más sencilla de hacerlo
era colocando el Sol
en el centro del sistema.
Redescubrió el modelo heliocéntrico
en apenas unas pocas horas.
Algo que a la humanidad
le llevó tantos siglos.
Ya no está tan claro que los ordenadores
sean una mera herramienta
para hacer ciencia tradicional
pero muy avanzada.
Ahora también nos proporcionan
modelos de universo.
Pueden hacer ciencia.
Y si estas nuevas criaturas
se alimentan de datos,
con todo este aluvión
que se nos viene encima,
al menos en astrofísica,
¿qué otras cosas nos revelarán
las máquinas acerca del universo,
que jamás podríamos alcanzar
con nuestro hardware biológico?
O algo que a mí me inquieta aún más:
¿Serán los ordenadores
los científicos del futuro?
Si el mensaje del cosmos
es que somos insignificantes,
mi esperanza es que,
al menos nuestras creaciones,
aquellas que pueden perdurar, no lo sean.
Gracias
(Aplausos)